today's video is brought to you by babel
the number one language app in the world
with more than 10
million subscribers worldwide the world
is getting smaller and smaller
and your list of reasons for learning
another language is getting bigger and
bigger
so whether your language needs are tied
to international travel professional
necessity or just personal curiosity
there's no better option
than babel now you might have had a
crack at this already with some basic
free apps from the app store but babel
goes way beyond the basics with 14
languages
and proven learning techniques so why is
babel better well with babel you can
count on people who have actual
experience teaching the language rather
than just relying on machine learning
like other apps do
it's also totally ad free which means
it's distraction free that way you can
just focus on the learning it'll also
focus on language for real life teaching
you about situations you'll actually
encounter
less bibliotheca and more vino if
you know what i mean and if you don't
well you should get babble and with
babble it's really easy to just jump in
and practice whenever you have a down
moment and those short few minutes of
practice they all
do add up start learning a new language
today with babble and
for a limited time you can get up to 65
percent off the cost of a subscription
there's a link below
was there ever such a thing as a good
pirate
sure they might be popular today but
there's no denying in their own time
they were responsible for a lot of
hardship
and sorrow the freedom the danger and
the careless life on the open sea might
have romanticized pirates in our minds
but
they were still ruthless criminals who
at their best robbed victims and
at their worst tortured raped and
murdered them there was
a certain level of violence that was to
be expected as a pirate especially if
you wanted to climb through the ranks
but what happened when a captain really
wanted to avoid violence as much as
possible
and when he got into trouble with his
own men because they thought he was too
soft on their victims
this is a story of edward england a
pirate captain who tried to spare the
lives of his fiercest enemies and was
marooned
by his own men for his efforts
[Music]
we have to start off with quick note
that we often include in our pirate
biographies one that we like to call
the johnson disclaimer as with many of
his compatriots the main contemporary
source for the life of edward england is
the book
general history of the pirates by
captain charles johnson whose
accuracy leaves something to be desired
not even the identity of the author is
truly known since
charles johnson was a pseudonym for one
or even
multiple writers with that in mind there
is a lot of uncertainty surrounding the
early life of edward england since
he does not really appear in the
historical record until he became a
sailor we are almost certain that
england was not his real name and some
sources claim that it was seeger and he
most likely adopted a pseudonym when he
raised the black flag and became a
pirate
as far as his date of birth is concerned
we know his approximate age when he died
so we can work
backwards and estimate that edward
england was born around 1685
and he was born in ireland despite his
adopted surname in november 1700 king
charles ii of spain died without an air
causing a power struggle for the throne
of the powerful spanish empire a few
months later this triggered the war
of spanish succession as one side wanted
philip of andrew part of the royal
french house of bourbon to
become the new king while the other side
feared that a strong alliance between
france and spain would have made them
too
powerful so they wanted the two kingdoms
to remain separate
england was in the second camp and since
maritime supremacy was something that
all the european powers coveted there
was always
a need for new sailors to take to the
seas that is
presumably how a young edward england
started his nautical career although we
do not know any specifics about his
service the war of spanish succession
ended in 1714
and as always in such situations this
created a new wave of pirates
up until that point many sailors
attacked and plundered other ships
legally as privateers as long as they
only targeted enemy ships and sent their
part of the prophets back to england
once the war was over however they were
no longer allowed to do that but at the
same time many of them
did not know or want to do anything else
so they saw no other choice but to turn
to piracy edward england was not one of
these men surprisingly after the war it
seems that he found legitimate
employment as a mate aboard a merchant
sloop sailing out of jamaica
however during one voyage the ship was
attacked by a pirate vessel captained by
a man named christopher winter who
forced england to join his crew winter
then sailed back to nassau on the island
of new providence
in the bahamas at the time nassau served
as a haven and
a base of operations for many pirates
active in the caribbean and
many notorious captains of that time
stopped at nassau around the same time
to trade and resupply they included
benjamin hornegold henry jennings
charles vane
blackbeard calico jack rack and many
many others
they even became known informally as the
flying gang and edward england joined
their
ranks
[Music]
england might have been reluctant to
become a pirate but ultimately he
accepted this new life captain johnson
described england as
one of these men who seemed to have such
a share of reason
as should have taught him better things
he had
a great deal of good nature and did not
want for courage he was not avaricious
and
always averse to the ill usage prisoners
received he would have been
contented with moderate plunder and less
mischievous pranks could
his companions have been brought to the
same temper
but he was generally overruled and as he
was engaged in that abominable society
he was obliged to be a partner in all
their vile actions
it is unknown how long england sailed
under captain winter but it was probably
only for a few months by 1716 he was
part of henry jennings's crew
fighting to recover the spanish treasure
that sank off the coast of florida
the 1715 treasure fleet is a legendary
chapter in nautical law one that
directly spurred on the so-called golden
age of piracy that followed spanish
succession on july 24 1715 a fleet of 12
spanish ships left havana
heading back home to spain they were all
filled to the brim with treasure
particularly gold coins and silver
seven days later on july the 31st the
treasure fleet encountered a hurricane
off the central coast of florida as the
powerful winds and waves batted the ship
to pieces
only one managed to escape the other
eleven sank to the bottom of the seed
taking over a thousand sailors to their
watery graves as well as one of the
greatest treasures in the world
unsurprisingly the temptation was too
great for people to simply sit idly by
and let the spanish recover their gold
like many of israel henry jennings had
been a privateer but
now that the war was over his status was
a bit murky he had been
based out of jamaica a british
possession at the time operating with
the permission of the governor lord
archibald hamilton when news reached him
of the sunken
fleet he boarded a ship the boshiba and
sean to florida raiding the coastal
villages that recovered part of the
treasure that washed ashore
of course this was only the beginning as
the boshiba and other vessels intended
to salvage the entire fleet but this was
not something spain would simply allow
this
wasn't a single privateer committing a
random attack on a merchant ship an
isolated incident that would have been
overlooked even in peacetime since a
treaty had been signed between the two
countries spain demanded that the
english ships end their salvaging
attempts immediately
some of them did for others however the
allure of spanish gold was just
too good to pass up so they abandoned
the english flag
and became pirates that was the case
with henry jennings who
then had to leave jamaica and settle in
nassau he was soon joined by other
pirates such as benjamin hornergold
edward teach charles vane and of course
edward england all of whom
intended to use the island of new
providence as their headquarters while
they conducted raids in the waters off
the coast of florida this led
to a few years of intense pirate
activity in the caribbean until
eventually the british crown decided
that enough was enough and appointed
captain woods rogers as the first
governor of the bahamas in 1717 giving
him the task of suppressing piracy in
the region to accomplish this rogers
knew that he had to take nassau he
arrived there in 1718 with a fleet and
barring one skirmish with charles vane
he managed to assume control of the port
city
without much incident rogers also came
with an offer of peace king george the
first of prison had
issued a royal decree which became known
as the king's pardon it was a one-time
deal
any pirate who wanted to renounce their
old ways could accept the king's pardon
and receive complete amnesty for
whatever they had done
those who refused the offer or who
reneged on the deal would be hunted down
and executed with nassau in british
hands hundreds of pirates accepted the
pardon
this included henry jennings who retired
a wealthy man on a plantation and
benjamin hornegold who became a pirate
hunter and
fought his former compatriots others
such as charles vane and jack rackham
had
no interest in any other life but that
of a pirate so
they continued as they were until their
inevitable doom
at the end of a noose curiously edward
england did not take the pardon
even though it could have been his one
chance to resume his old
life by 1718 he was a captain of his own
ship which he named
the fancy in honor of henry every and
even though he had been reluctant to
become a pirate it seems
that now he had little desire to go back
when bahamas became too dangerous
for the likes of him england and his
crew sailed the coasts of africa
once he reached africa it seemed like
england's practical career began in
earnest
he started taking prizes by which we
mean attacking and plundering other
ships and the first of which we are well
informed was a snowship sailing out of
bristol called cadigan
according to charles johnson this ship
was commanded by a man named skinner who
used to be the captain for several of
the pirate crewmen back when they still
sailed under the british crown
apparently the men were not happy with
how skinner treated them so
they took this opportunity to have their
revenge on him they tied the captain up
and pelted him with empty bottles
when they had had their fun they shot
him in the head curiously the ship's
mate a man named hal davis was
unperturbed by the pirates actions and
wanted to join their ranks he took
command of the cadigan and sailed for
south america starting his own
successful stint as a pirate captain as
far as edward england was concerned 1719
was probably his most successful year as
he captured well over a dozen prizes
with little effort and few losses this
included a ship called the pearl under
the command of captain tizard which
england kept for himself renamed the
royal james and made his new flagship of
the other prizes taken by england and
his crew some were added to his fleet
some were
let go and others were burned besides
their numerous encounters with other
ships
england and his crew also had a violent
fight with the locals in a port town
where
they docked for a few weeks to resupply
and make repairs on their ships
as charles johnson very delicately put
it the pirates were making
free with the town women which
eventually angered the local men enough
to start a fight with england's crew
unfortunately for the residents their
pirates won and not only did they kill a
bunch of locals but they also set the
town on fire on their way out
afterwards the pirates held a vote on
where they should go next and they
settled on the east indies so
edward england left the coast of
southern africa and headed for the
indian ocean they arrived at madagascar
at the beginning of 1720
they used the island as a headquarters
while they targeted mainly indian and
dutch merchant ships most of england's
targets were easy pickings but that
changed when he ran into captain james
macrae of the cassandra
[Music]
the cassandra was a british ship that
was prepared for a fight and unwilling
to simply capitulate to pirates
fortunately for us we have a first-hand
account of the violent events that
unfolded courtesy of captain mcrae
himself who provided the details in a
letter
dated bombay november 16 1720. since
it's quite
long here's an abridged version with all
the juicy bits we arrived at the 25th of
july last in company of the greenwich at
joanna we found 14 pirates that came in
their canoes from the miata captain
kirby and i concluding it
might be of great service to the east
india company to destroy such a nest of
rogues were
ready to sail for that purpose on the
17th of august about
eight o'clock in the morning when we
discovered two pirate ships standing in
the bay of juana
one of 34 and the other of 30 guns
i immediately went on board the
greenwich where they seemed very
diligent in preparations for an
engagement
i left captain kirby with mutual
promises of standing by each other
i called several times the greenwich to
bear down to our assistance and ferd
shot at him but to no purpose because
when he got about a league from us he
deserted
us and left us engaged with barbarous
and inhuman enemies with their black and
bloody flags hanging over us we
engaged them both about three hours
during which the
biggest received some shot betwixt wind
and water
which made her keep off a little to stop
her leaks the other endeavored as she
could to board us by
rowing with her oars being within half a
ship's length of us above an hour
but by good fortune we shot all her oars
to pieces which prevented them and by
consequence saved our lives about four
o'clock most of the officers and men
posted on the court deck being killed
and wounded we endeavoured to run ashore
here we had a more violent engagement
than before all my officers and most of
my men behaved with unexpected courage
and as we had a considerable advantage
by having a broadside to his bow we did
him great
damage but the other pirate supplied his
consort with
three boats full of fresh men about five
in the evening the
greta stood clear away to sea leaving us
struggling hard for
life in the very jaws of death which the
other pirate that was afloat
seeing got a warp out and was hauling
under our stern by which time many of my
men being killed and wounded and
no hopes left us from being all murdered
by enraged barbarous conquerors i
ordered
all that could to get into the longboat
under the cover
of the smoke of our guns so that with
what some did in boats and
others by swimming most of us that were
able got ashore
by seven o'clock when the pirates came
aboard they cut three of our wounded men
to pieces
i with a few of my people made what
haste i could to the king's town 25
miles from us
where i arrived next day almost dead
with fatigue and loss of blood having
been
sorely wounded in the head by a musket
ball edward england had won
the engagement as his enemies fled into
the jungle however it came with a heavy
price as
england had lost around 90 crewmen in
the fight and one of his two ships the
fancy had been
damaged almost beyond repair the royal
james had also taken a battering and now
the pirates would have to spend a few
weeks on the island in order to make it
seaworthy again
unsurprisingly the heavy losses led to
strong resentment among the bloodthirsty
pirates particularly towards the
remaining crew of the cassandra who were
hiding out somewhere in the nearby
jungle but the survivors had no way of
leaving the island so a little choice
left captain mcrae contacted the pirates
and traveled aboard the royal james to
surrender
and hope for mercy this was when the
crew started to turn against england
because
they felt he was too forgiving for a
pirate he indeed wanted to show the
survivors of the cassandra mercy but
he was also aware that he was heavily in
the minority as most of his crew wanted
to cut mccrae and his
men to pieces therefore he told mcrae
that he needed to convince his
second-in-command john taylor captain of
the
heavily damaged fancy this was easier
said than done because
taylor described as a fellow of most
barbarous nature was nowhere near as
compassionate as england therefore
mccray decided to forego appealing to
his humanity
and tried a different tactic flying with
alcohol this strategy worked taylor got
wasted enough that he consented to give
mccrae his
former ship and a few bales of cloth
before passing out and drunken stupid
pirates sailed away on september the
third aboard the royal james and the
cassandra meanwhile mcrae and 43 of his
men who survived the fight spent another
week on the island performing repairs on
the fancy in order to make it as
seaworthy as possible but despite their
hardships now came the most difficult
part of all
as mcrae and his crew had to sail to
india through treacherous seas
aboard a damaged vessel with very little
food and water
the captain describes his ordeal after a
passage of 48 days i arrived here
october the 22nd
almost naked and starved having been
reduced to a pint of water a day and
almost in despair of ever seeing land by
reason
of the calms we met with between the
coasts of arabia
and malabar we had in all 13 men killed
and 24 wounded it's a bit unclear
what happened to mcrae immediately
following his arrival in bombay
word reached the pirate that the former
captain of the cassandra had been
given a commission to hunt them down and
had already secured a new ship and crew
and was in pursuit
whether or not this was true is the
uncertain part but just the threat of it
sealed the fate of edward england most
of his crew were already angry with him
due to his gentle demeanor unbefitting a
pirate captain in their minds
and john taylor already has his sight
sets on the captaincy
so they knew to lead against england and
taylor assumed command of the ship
as for the former captain his punishment
was marooning england was abandoned on a
desert island with only a few days worth
of food and water it's unclear if he was
also given a pistol with just one bullet
to spare himself a slow agonizing death
or if this was an invention of hollywood
either way he was not alone as three
crewmen stood by their captain
and they were also left behind normally
marooning meant certain death either
through dehydration starvation or
drowning when they tried to escape the
island
but there are a handful of cases where
the victims survived the most famous
being that of alexander selkirk the man
who inspired robinson crusoe in the case
of edward england his good fortune was
the island where he was marooned
back then it was a french possession
known as alder france though
today we'd call it mauritius the french
had claimed it around 1715
after the dutch abandoned it but they
were yet to colonize it so it was truly
deserted
but there was plenty to hunt on the
island so the four marooned men did not
suffer for a lack of food and
thanks to the dutch they found
themselves some abandoned structures
which they recycled for building
materials
after a few months on the island they
had managed to make themselves a little
boat that they used to sail to
saint augustine's bay in madagascar if
this was a fictional story this would
probably be
just the beginning of the third act when
edward england would secure a new ship
and a new crew and
sail out to get revenge on the people
who marooned him but the truth is that
the ordeal took a great toll on him and
england arrived in madagascar in very
poor health not to mention that he
didn't have a single penny to his name
he was reduced to begging and relying on
the charity of other pirates who
once knew him charles johnson does not
mention edward england's ultimate fate
although
other sources claim that he died shortly
after in 1721 purportedly of some
tropical disease
it was an ignoble death one
ill-befitting a man whose
main perceived flaw was that he was too
compassionate
for his own good so i really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below don't forget to subscribe please
do check out fantastic sponsor babble as
well link below
and thank you for watching